him sweetgrass I've given him stage and
today I plan to give him some cedar to
make sure that the words that are spoken
today go up to where they need to be
heard I first I first learned about the
senator in 2015 like many of us who were
all so devoted to doing the right thing
I quickly joined him in his presidential
race as a delegate from South Dakota I
traveled to the DNC and got as involved
as I possibly could and eventually it
led me to the occupation of my father's
homelands in Standing Rock North Dakota
doing the right thing became the basis
for this national network of organizers
and people who were like-minded and they
were actually the first people to show
up after the DNC to standing around to
help support our cause against the
Dakota access pipeline it was this
network of doing the right thing that
really embraced a lot of us you know
Bernie Sanders was able to bring our
causes to the forefront and never in
history have we had a presidential
candidate supportive like Bernie has and
so I really want to take the time to
thank the senator his organization's our
revolution Deb Parker has been an
amazing influence on my life as well as
Nicole Willis who is with the natives
for bernie team sorry i'm trying to get
emotional the people's for bernie team
also on the internet has been a huge
influence in spreading our messages in
supporting a cause so i really want to
thank a lot of my mosh gay that are
watching now i always want to thank
everybody else who showed up and
supported us during our fight and
continue to support us in our fight here
against what's going on in the world i'm
really proud of the consistency that the
senator continues to show and so I
really want you guys
take everything in right now and um
annachi cope with occupy welcome senator
bernie sanders
[Applause]
thank you all very much for allowing me
to be with you this afternoon and it
truly is an honor to be with you and I
will tell you why the American people
especially the young people understand
very profoundly what the Native American
people have gone through in their
history and you would be very surprised
like an around the country a whole lot
and you would be I think surprised and
delighted to know how appreciative the
people of this country are in general
and young people in particular for the
incredible legacy that the Native
American people have given us your
culture your respect for the environment
your willingness to think generations in
front rather than focusing on short-term
profits has had a profound impact upon
millions and millions of people in this
country and I thank you very much for
that
and that is the good news in a good news
that everybody in this room should be
proud of the bad news is I think we
understand not only the history of what
has happened in America for the last 500
or so years the lies that have been told
to the Native Americans the treaties
that have been signed but then abrogated
the taking away of sovereignty that had
been promised the refusal to listen to
the pain of the Native American people
from way back till today is something
that my wife Jane where Jane she here
stand up Jane if you could please Jane
and I feel very strongly and I want to
say that during the last campaign I ran
in 2016 we had the opportunity quite
intentionally to visit reservations in
Native American communities because we
thought it was terribly important but
the plight and the suffering of the
Native American people be made known to
the whole country and are proud of the
role that I played in trying to raise
consciousness about what is happening
I'll never forget going to Pine Ridge
and learning that a life expectancy in
that reservation is in fact where many
poor third-world countries are and it is
no secret to you that the health care
system that now exists for the Native
American people is nowhere near where it
should be and we are going to improve
that we are gonna fight for a Medicare
for All single-payer system and in the
middle that we are going to make sure
that the Native American people have
comprehensive health care as a human
right not as a privilege
and our job is also and I know how
important it is to protect the sacred
lands of the Native American people I
was proud to have been there not
physically but in every other way
standing with the Native American people
at Standing Rock and I do that I do that
a because it is imperative that we
respect the sovereignty and the land
that is sacred to the Native American
people but in addition to that for your
children and your grandchildren and mine
as well we must do everything we can to
address the existential crisis facing
this planet in terms of climate change
and that is why together together we are
going to take on the fossil fuel
industry and tell them that their
short-term profits are not more
important than the future of our planet
and if there's anything in the culture
of the Native American people it is
precisely that to understand the greed
and short term profits are not more
important than the way people live in
the sanctity of our land I am aware also
then I guess we'll discuss this any
moment about the epidemic which now
exists exists in terms of violence
against women and this is an issue that
will be very very high up on my agenda
we will see cooperation between the
federal government and the sovereign
Indian nations in order to address this
crisis last point that I want to make
and there are so many you
shoes that are out there is that I know
that many people in the Native American
community feel that the federal
government for years has turned their
backs on your issues and your concerns
at best you have been able to get a seat
at the table
but as often as that has taken place
your words and your concerns have not
been heard you can talk but nobody
listens and we intend to change that we
intend if there's anybody if it is not
you who should be involved in
determining Native American policy in
the United States that I don't know who
should be involved certainly not a bunch
of bureaucrats in Washington so I want
to thank you all personally and Jane has
been deeply involved in these issues for
years and I want to thank you for
reminding the American people about some
very very deep values that we must
adhere to and that is respect for the
environment respect for the land respect
for our traditions respect for promises
made to a people that have been broken
and I know it has been a long and
painful history I know that in your
communities the arrival of Columbus is
not something that is widely celebrated
but I think it is time to turn the road
I think it is time to fundamentally
change US government policy to the
Native American people and as president
of the United States I would be so
pleased to help lead that effort with
you thank you so much
[Applause]
please no no no you stay down
Thank You senator welcome thank you very
much we're beginning our questions with
the words of an elder Marcelo LaBolt
my name is Marcelo Lyubov from the shine
River Reservation from the to kettle
band and I'm honored to be in group
residence just mr. Sanders I want to say
that I had the honor and privilege of
being a nurse in World War two I served
him Wales England France and Belgium and
that was my great honour but I do have a
question and this relates to the
massacre at Wounded Knee and to me my
personal opinion there is a pervasive
sadness that exists on our reservation
because of unresolved grief when these
20 medals of Honor were given to the 7th
Calvary soldiers when they at the
massacre at Wounded Knee when they
killed approximately 250 women and
children and in the reader who was ill
with pneumonia and so all of these
things have a bearing on what the
feelings and helplessness of people on
our reservation they orders the children
everyone and so my question is will you
support the removal of the stain act
that is my question the answer is
absolutely
[Applause]
medals of Honor are given rarely and
they're given to people who do very very
important things and I want to thank you
for your work I know you received
recognition I believe from the French
government and elsewhere for the work
you have done in world war ii and saving
lives that's the type of a person who
receives medals alona they're very rare
and they're given to people who show
great great bravery massacring women in
children is not an act of great bravery
it is an act of depravity depravity you
know this afternoon and in the few
minutes that I have here we're not going
to resolve all of the issues of the last
500 years but I think it is important
not differently by the way that how we
deal with the abomination of slavery
that the time is long overdue for us to
be having that discussion of what
happened when the first settlers came
here and the terrible and horrible
things that were done to the Native
American people not only at Wounded Knee
but in so many other places I think that
is a discussion that the American people
actually want to have and at the end of
that discussion must be the necessity of
us doing everything that we can to
repair the damage the psychological
damage the humiliations and also address
the real needs of the Native American
people today who in many cases are
living in poverty so there's a lot of
work to be done but to acknowledge and
it will not be easy a lot of pain there
but to acknowledge what the settlers
have did when they came here and what
has happened over the last many many
years is something that this country is
going to have to address and as
president I look forward to addressing
it with you thank you
[Applause]
our next question comes from face
spotted eagle
Oh how many Tokyo PU here can you scan
Apache is a damper to kill you period
okay
I'm pair to do tone she who you could be
there
Oh young care dead Edna kept peeking her
a Hanukkah judicata we encourage a Hong
Kong on ki jiye P dared a tonic G 1858
treaty well here when I so tepee a
charity ok many agora ohina ohina in
Michalka H oh you know nawicki cheesy
actor oh you know hatchet atomic de
damper to you period
I bet you spot me I'm bad day was j-just
ESS me yeah I'm a cool truck sure of the
Braveheart society Mike who she asked me
to translate for her because she is
worried about her grandchildren's
grandchildren's future and whence to
pursue I preserve our language Mike who
she is faith
spotty ego standing stone of the Yankton
we offer you a friendly handshake from
our homelands she is 70 years old and
fought for her water since her home of
the White Swan was destroyed by the for
Randall dam on the Missouri River she is
chair of the Yankton treaty community
member of the Braveheart society and she
is though
she's the only Native American woman to
receive an electoral vote from the
present president of the u.s. in 2016
this is my cushy
[Applause]
the other reason I wanted talk OSHA to
do this is it's really lack of protocol
for us to introduce ourselves in in
native camps and to brag about ourselves
so I couldn't say all those things about
myself so somebody might think I'm lying
so my my granddaughter has rescued me
the other thing is that I wanted to show
the face of the grandchildren that this
is truly what we are here for today and
with adult isn't sometimes we don't make
room so here they are this is the Dakota
language we have three dialects Dakota
Lakota and Dakota but we understand each
other when we want to are from the a lot
of the what she - people couldn't
pronounce our names so they call a Sioux
but we are Dakota Lakota Dakota so
tribes shouldn't have to expend our
scarce resources to protect our drinking
water our land our people the fish and
the animals in that water the federal
government is required to protect us
through this trust responsibility that
was signed by my grandfather and many
other grandfathers that gave over
200,000 acres half of South Dakota so we
have prepaid health care we had many
prepaid issues that are not being lived
up to our subsistence practices our
gathering rights ceremonial cultural use
our water security reproductive justice
should be productive not further
polluted through fracking k XL pipeline
line three other pipelines and corporate
intrusions specifically foreign direct
investment in development that
disregards and deletes us this is proven
to increase the incidence of thousands
of murdered and missing women the MM IW
which you most articulately addressed
our women are traditionally held up as
keepers of the water
the first water is
medicine in the womb now besides
protecting our water we are forced to
prepare for the onslaught and
destructive force for from thousands of
men in a word that is very misogynistic
in nature it's called man camps so that
word itself is very misogynistic it's
violent and it actually the mmm iw issue
is not new the thousands of men who came
to our territory in the form of the
forts I live at Fort Randall and that
was an example of the mmm iw that came
at the very first contact even leading
back to Columbus who captured some of
our women so it's important to put that
in perspective but this of course is not
just about us this pipeline these
fracking efforts these environmental
destructions are not for our benefit the
public interest but they actually are
predator economics they're created in a
corporate purpose which has nothing to
do with the people of this land the
other thing I want to say is that as of
PTSD therapist and as a person who helps
people heal the word PTSD is a misnomer
I'm thinking about renaming it CT SB
which is concurring continual traumatic
stress disorder because the trauma never
ended when we say PTSD we act like it
happened in the 1800's it is happening
every single day the other issue that
comes to mind with mm iw is that it's
almost government policy that we are not
grievable so thousands of women are
killed but the corporate people say oh
section 106 consultation will take care
of that saying that you can't grieve
even though you're your baby girls have
died so that's the government policy is
that we are not grievable that's a
violation of a human right the other
thing is with endangered species we have
a whole different language and the
language is capitalism versus ended
indigenous values because for us there
is no such thing as separation from
animal we have a lion
of sustainable development with our
relatives and you notice that the
animals are starting to attack the
humans we've had Buffalo attack we've
had bear attacks but they know that we
are not living up to the alliance that
we had originally that we would protect
them they even offer their lives up so
we can live and so the animal nation
knows that and so we have to pay
attention the other thing when we talk
about the public benefit it's really
important to realize that we live in one
of the most violent countries of the
world we live in systems of violence
that are benevolent in nature Indian
Health Service is benevolent in nature
I'm sitting here with a knee that needs
to be replaced and it's going on 15
years and because my limb is not
destroyed enough I'm not dying that
Indian Health Service will not honor my
treaty right so I appreciate all of you
that helped me as I continue to fight
for this old knee but those are the
issues unless you are almost dead you
don't get any help from a treaty right
that my grandfather and many of your
people so what we're talking about is
institutional racism so now I'll get to
my question but I know that our friend
if I can call you Bernie has already
addressed this but I think it's a deeper
issue we had a wonderful person from the
Danae Nation talk this morning and he
talked about consultation is just an
artificial thing what has to be changed
is the basis of a country that considers
itself a concur and has created laws
that benefit only them consultation
needs to be consent and it's it's so my
question for you how will you promote
and protect the exercise of a tribal
inherent Aboriginal and treaty rights on
water and public land and further to do
an investigator
a congressional review of how Fort
Randall dam was built illegally Ahn
jung-hwan Lance that's my question thank
you
I begin the language was speaking was
Lakota yes okay doc cotton and it
reminds me and this is a language now
that you are struggling to preserve to
make sure that the young people can
learn it you can know it okay and it it
speaks to me when I hear the language of
which of course I did not understand one
word but it speaks to me the importance
of us knowing where we came from if
we're gonna know where we're going
forward and the need to preserve as much
as we can the culture in the history of
the United States which among other
things means language to make sure that
our kids Native American kids and kids
all over this country understand the
history of their country their real
history where they came from and the
languages that those who came before
them spoke and count me as an ally to
provide the financial resources which is
not easy not many people probably are
still speaking that language is that
correct all right and it's terribly
important that it be preserved you
raised a number of questions as I
mentioned earlier it is unacceptable to
me that treaty signed and agreements
made within rescinded was simply not
acknowledged and that is the history of
the Native American people yeah so you
have a treaty as I think you indicated
which says you are guaranteed health
care as they right and that treaty has
certainly been abrogated and I think we
all understand that the Indian Health
Service is not doing anywhere near what
it should be doing as somebody who
believes absolutely that health care is
a human right for the Native American
people and for everybody else we will
reform fundamentally the Indian Health
Service
so that it will take care of your knee
and the needs of all Native American
people and the truth of the matter is
you know I know people say well you know
the truth is this within the context of
a multi trillion dollar federal
government is not an expensive
proposition we can provide quality
health care to every Native American
person and trust me it'll cost a lot
less than one new weapon system for the
Pentagon it all right so so this is not
this is not you know some kind of
outrageous promise that I'm making do it
really is not all that expensive and
it's something that is doing you raise
other issues you raise the issue about
corporate corporations fossil fuel
corporations coming in trying to X
either excavate for minerals or develop
fuel lines and pipelines that will
transport fossil fuel and I respond to
you in two ways that you are right
consultation is not the issue the issue
is signing off on something saying I
agree with it or not so we are not going
to be an administration says well here
it is I'm consulting you as to what we
are doing we will sit down as equals
here your point of view and we will work
out an agreement that works for you
second point in terms of fossil fuels
and the pipelines as I said a moment ago
climate change is threatening not only
your way of life not only the United
States of America it is threatening the
entire planet all right and it pains me
it pains me very much that we have a
president who believes that climate
change is a hoax it is not a hoax it is
a threat to this country and every
country on Earth and as president of the
United States my job will be to stand up
to the fossil fuel industry in this
country
and tell them that their short-term
profits are not more important than the
future of our planet
and to reach out to countries all over
the world because this is not just a
problem that we can solve alone right
now around this world nations are
spending somewhere around a trillion and
a half dollars on weapons of destruction
designed to kill each other and maybe
just maybe if we had adequate leadership
in the White House the most powerful
government on earth maybe we can't
convince governments all over the world
that instead of spending a trillion and
a half dollars a year killing each other
maybe we should use those resources
combine those resources against our
common enemy which is climate change and
save the planet for our children and our
grandchildren and the last point that I
want to make and I made this I met with
some of you in Detroit a few weeks ago
and I think the question was will you
hear from us will you will you allow us
to participate and the answer is we will
do more than that because you have so
much to explain and teach the people of
our country about respect for nature
working and you indicated with the
animals working understanding that we
are part of nature we can't go to war
against nature and then expect to have
clean water or decent food and if
there's any people in this country today
who know what that is about it is you
and we need you to help explain that not
only to our country but to the world you
have a history which is rich and
important and at this moment of
environmental crises this is the time
for the Native American people working
with an administration that respects the
Native American people to help us
transform our entire economy to one
which is not at war with nature but is
part of nature
our next question comes from Douglas Cox
the nominee hold on here we go anyway
mouthing up shakes we see in Wausau
Kenny
welcome senator thank you for being here
and participating in this forum I need
to really quickly also thank those that
lines that were on so the Omaha the
Winnebago the Dakota who are gracious
enough to allow us to be here on their
lines today so I say one wine and thank
you for that I also like to say thank
you really quick for directions or Jay
and his folks have done an exceptional
job putting this together so oh and for
that I also brought a youth with me
senator so seated to my right is Forrest
cedar Fernandes so I brought her with me
she's traveled been here both days this
truly is our future this is what we're
embedded for and that's why she's here
so so I've got a little bit of
repetitiveness so I know you know I'm in
your intro you talked about climate
change and you just answered that again
so I apologize for that but I'm gonna
really quickly give you one specific
question at the end so tribes have
historically lived from the land and
today is no different we have located
ourselves in these places that are
environmentally significant waterways
forests prairies and mountains but today
these places are threatened by
developments carbon footprint resulting
in floods temperature changes loss and
diversity impacts to plants animals and
tree species which in turn are
threatening our ways of life these
changes are already resulting in coastal
impacts melting ice rising water levels
have literally forced our native peoples
to relocate historic villages that have
been there for generations historic fish
migrations are being interrupted animal
patterns are impacted wildfires are
dynamically changing burning hotter and
longer today tribes
have the option of migrating to areas of
historic occupation were limited to our
reservation boundaries which were
created when our ancestors signing those
treaties with the US government case in
point is our Menominee tribe located in
Midwest and central Wisconsin we have
long been recognized for worldwide
sustainable forestry practices
maintaining our diverse quarter million
acres of forest over the past hundreds
of years now in a face of a warming
climate invasive species regional
vegetation composition changes our
forests and our historic way of life are
facing serious threats so when you
combine this as you stated with the
current administration that's rolling
back protections like the clean power
plan lifting moratoriums on coal burning
power and opening our sacred lands to
minerals and energy extractions like in
Menominee's case trying to protect our
sacred Menomonee River from a large mine
development called the back 40 mine an
open pit travesty we ask that ask you
that how will your administration take
climate change and specific climate
challenges faced by tribal communities
well in a few ways number one we will
respect tribal sovereignty and we will
not turn our backs as large corporations
sometimes corporations from other
countries come in and rape the land that
belongs to the Native American people
that's number one number two we will
work with you I mean this is as I
mentioned again let me stress this again
because I am sincere in saying this I'm
not here just to say we're gonna do this
for you I need you to play a leadership
role in terms of sustainability you have
your people more than any people in our
country can teach us about
sustainability all right the Native
American people did not kill thousands
of
the Buffalo because they understood that
the Buffalo gave them life am i right on
that sustainability you don't wipe out
the trees
you don't DeForest and Brazil right now
as we speak this massive deforestation
going on which will impact the entire
planet people want to make money they
want more land for whatever they wanted
for they want the trees but what the
Native American people can teach us and
I'm not an expert on it you know more
about it than I do
we need that wisdom now more than ever
this planet is right now on the verge
you talked about rising sea levels on ik
ice melting coastal areas flooding July
last month was the warmest month ever
recorded Europe having heat waves we
need to radically rethink our
relationship to nature okay so we will
protect of course the Native American
areas land that you own that is yours
from foreign invasion and more than that
we have got to work together not easy
stuff we got our very limited amount of
time before irreparable damage is done
to this planet okay how do we move
aggressively forward in terms of energy
efficiency how do we move forward in
terms of sustainable agriculture how do
we move forward in terms of more and
more solar and wind energy and other
forms of sustainable technology not easy
stuff but that is what we are gonna have
to do if we're going to preserve this
planet for our children and our
grandchildren and in my administration
it's not a question of listening to the
Native American people it is having you
up there up front giving us your history
and your culture about how we can work
with nature and not against nature
[Applause]
I'm really hoping we can get the last
few questions in so we're going into the
speed round
Janet Davis voting hearse from Pyramid
Lake okay good afternoon I'm honored to
be here today with you and I'm glad that
you came to see us and talk to our
tribal leaders and our communities my
question is about equal access to voting
in 2016 us judge do granted a temporary
injunction in Reno Nevada requiring the
establishment a satellite polling sites
to to Nevada reservations my tribe the
pyramid lake paiute tribe and the Walker
River Paiute Tribe members of our tribes
are being denied equal access to the
polls due to long distances polling
booths were set up for both on election
day as were the early voting sites the
county told us it was too late to
recruit and train poll workers and we
told them we could and we did our to
Nevada tribes have set the standard in
2016 to equal access to voting for
tribal citizens on reservations in the
United States we hope to lead the way
for other tribes as our vote is our
voice my question to you is how will you
ensure that all Native Americans on
reservations have the same access
without having to litigate as we did may
I be blunt and straightforward we have a
corrupt political system designed to
protect the wealthy and the powerful
[Applause]
what happened to your people is just one
example of the kind of voter suppression
that is taking place all over this
country you would think that in a
democratic society every elected
official would say our voter turnout is
not as high as we would like it to be
many other countries have higher voting
turnout rates what do we do to get more
people involved in the political process
how do we end up having the highest
voter turnout rate of any country on
Earth because we believe in democracy
one person one vote all right but what
you got right now are two things and
again I'm gonna be I guess I don't
apologize for being partisan I am
running for president of the United
States so I'll be a little bit partisan
all right you got a Republican Party out
there that really understands that they
cannot win elections based on their
policies not only their policies against
the Native American people but their
policies in general most Americans don't
believe we should give tax breaks to
billionaires most Americans don't
believe we should ignore climate change
most Americans don't believe we should
cut Social Security Medicare Medicaid
and education that's not what the
American people believe that is
literally the program of the Republican
Party now if you have a program that
most people reject how do you win
elections well you win elections in two
ways number one you create a process by
which billionaires and very very wealthy
people can buy elections by being able
to contribute hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars so issue number one
is the need to overturn a disastrous
Supreme Court decision called Citizens
United
[Music]
billionaires do not have the right to
buy elections democracy is one person
one book you get a vote and you get a
vote and you get a vote majority wins
now the second thing they do is after
they have their billionaire friends
buying elections then they still gotta
worry there's you got a lot of working
people and low-income people who are
prepared to vote to fight for health
care for all to make sure that all of
our kids regardless of income can get a
higher education
which is why we're fighting to make
public colleges and universities
tuition-free a lot of people including
me believe that we should cancel all
student debt in America that we should
raise the minimum wage to a living wage
of at least fifteen bucks an hour now
and then we need criminal justice reform
and immigration for all these issues out
there so if you got people who believe
in that how do I win an election if I
believe everything opposite of that I
make it harder for people to vote and
the people I am targeting now are people
of color Native American people Latino
people African American people I target
young people i target young people in
New Hampshire right now a very
deliberate effort to make it harder for
young people to participate in the
political process so that is what's
going on what is the answer the answer
is to have a president and an attorney
general who's going to do everything
that we can to make sure that every
eligible voter in this country is able
to vote we're gonna take on voter
suppression in all of its forms and that
means you don't you don't take make it
impossible to get to a polling place
which was your case it means also that
we move toward a sister
which says very simply that in the
United States of America if you are 18
years of age or older you have the right
to vote end of discussion
so this is an issue we feel strongly
about this is when it's no fun to be a
moderator I'm afraid our time has
expired and I know this is a
conversation that could go on for
another hour please give a thank you to
senator Sanders
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you